sur le terrain des opérations Ukraine
sachez que des explosions authentices ce
samedi matin à Kiev mais aussi à
carquish c'est ce qu'on t'indiquer les
autorités de cette ville à qui est-ce la
défense entière est en train d'action
selon l'administration de la capitale
ukrainienne il y aurait des dégâts
matériels et humains au moins cette
blessée cette dernière heure de
nombreuses frapperons sont touchées des
villes comme parquet on l'a dit hachers
ou encore ni pro la correspondance de
Gulliver Craig
des fragments ont touché les étages
supérieurs d'un immeuble d'appartement
détruisant quelques appartements et
faisant plusieurs blessés en plus de ces
deux personnes qui ont été tuées sinon
il y a eu une vingtaine de drones et de
requêtes qui ont été abattues mais les
l'Armée de l'Air n'a pas encore publié à
cette déclaration pour donner le chiffre
exact ce n'est pas uniquement Kiev qui a
été frappé et ses frappes qui ont eu
lieu plusieurs vagues pendant la nuit il
y a eu plusieurs fois la sirène retentit
donc on a vraiment passé une nuit sans
sommeil c'est pas uniquement Kiev c'est
aussi ni prosa pourrija admis pro il y a
des blessés à zapporisa c'était des
missile
S300 sol mais je n'ai pas encore
d'informations sur d'éventuelles dégâts
ou victimes
voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire à l'heure
qu'il est de la situation en Ukraine